house of the dragon starts filming in a
few days and airs next year
this game of thrones prequel show will
tell the story of the dance of the
dragons
a targaryen civil war that took place
over 100 years before game of thrones
in january hb announced they are
developing a show based on georgia
martin's tales of duncan x series which
follows a legendary knight sir dunk the
toll and his squire
the targaryen prince egg this series is
set
90 years before game of thrones i could
tell you about sir duncan
at all those were always your favorites
raised this dunk in flea bottom duncan
became a squire of the hedge knight
orlean of penetry
duncan then travelled the seven kingdoms
as a hedge knight himself
with the young prince sake on targaryen
called egg as his choir
the early exploits of dunkin egg are
chronicled in a night of the seven
kingdoms
which collects the hedge knight the
sworn sword and the mystery knight
sir duncan the toll was a great night in
the history of westeros that served
loyally to house targaryen
he was a famous warrior and a great
friend and champion to king aegon the
fifth targaryen
he's immortalized in many songs and
stories
the pair of duncan egg had many famous
adventures
this included a visit to dorne where
they were nearly killed by the
apparently insane
lady of faith as well as resolving a
decades-long dispute between the houses
osgray and weber in the reach
they also helped foil the second
blackfyre rebellion
before undertaking a lengthy journey
north to visit winterfell
many years later egg ascended the iron
throne as king gaegon the 5th targaryen
sir duncan the tall became a member of
the kingsguard
and later it's lord commander duncan was
one of the heroes of the fourth
blackfyre rebellion
egg and dunk faced their last adventure
together at summerhall
on the night of the great fire which
killed them the same night rhaegar
targaryen was born there
hbo is also working on a show about
robert sebelian
which ended at 300 years old targaryen
dynasty in westeros
and almost ended targaryens themselves
to everyone who watched game of thrones
robert's rebellion is quite known
robert ned stark and john narran
rebelled against the mad king
and overthrow targaryens it lasted close
to a year and resulted in the end of the
targaryen dynasty in the seven kingdoms
and the beginning of robert baratheon's
reign it had ten major battles and
ultimately resulted with the victory
for the rebels the end of the targaryen
dynasty
and the start of the baratheon dynasty
this show will bring many characters we
know and love
back on the screens ned stark robert
baratheon diamond lannister rhaegar
targaryen elena stark the mad king etc
and if you thought this news was good
enough well there's more
as many as three more new game of
thrones prequels have been announced to
be in work
or rather in a developing stage in hbo
first of the three new prequels is
called ten thousand ships
ten thousand ships is a reference to the
journey made by warrior queen princess
nymeria
and the surviving members of the
rhoynar's who traveled from essos to
dorne
following their defeat by the valyrian
freehold in the second spice war
she lost but rather to submit to their
rule
she led her people across the narrow sea
and settled in dorne
which her descendants would rule for
generations to come
she and her people came to this new land
in 10 000
ships which nymeria burned preventing
any of her men from wanting to go home
or somewhere else and giving a clear
sign that this strange dornish land is
their new home
but legends often claim that nymeria
commanded a fleet of ten thousand ships
beldecar the inside of a song of ice and
fire author
of the history of the rhony schwartz
whose copy can be found in the red keeps
library
argues that the number was inflated
perhaps by tenfold
while other chroniclers suffered
different numbers in truth
no count was ever made maester yandal
agrees that nymeria led a great many
ships
mostly rivercraft skiffs pole boats
trading alleys
fishing boats rafts and pleasure barges
crammed with women children and old men
beldecker insists only one in ten will
save worthy
at the time of nymeria's arrival dorne
was a poor land where a score of lords
and petty kings squirreled over rivers
wells and fertile water many view the
rhoynar as unwelcome invaders
who should be driven back into the sea
however lord morse martel of the sand
ships saw an opportunity in the rhoynar
and singers claim that lord martel also
lost his heart to a beautiful princess
with many trained in warfare the rhoynar
added their strength
to lord martel's own increasing his host
by tenfold
morse married nymeria and hundreds of
his knights squires and bannermen vet
roy and schwimmin
uniting the two people by blood the
rhoynar also brought considerable wealth
with them
and their artisans and armored skills
were more far advanced than those of
their westerosi counterparts
to celebrate these unions and to ensure
that her people could not retreat
to the sea again nymeria burned her
fleet
declaring her wanderings to be at an end
although some of her people mourned the
loss of their ships
nymeria named her husband the prince of
dorne
declaring his dominion over all of dorne
however such supremacy was not an easy
feat
and years a war followed called
nymeria's war
the rhoynar and the martel subdued one
petty king after another
and now fewer than six kings were sent
to the wall to join the night's watch by
nymeria and her husband
soon only king york the fifth wiring
would remain
the greatest of the dornish kings
nymeria and martel's battled against
ironwood and his batterman for nine
years
when her husband fell to wyronwood's
sword in the third battle of the boneway
nymeria soon sole command of the martel
armies
two more years of battle followed but
nymeria eventually defeated yorick v
and he bent the knee to her ensuring
martel's supremacy
thereafter nymeria ruled from sunspear
the new seat of house martel
built around sandship this migration
took place
around 1 000 years before the events
depicted in a song of ice and fire
novels
arya stark named her direwolf after
nymeria
the second the new prequel is named flea
bottom
flea bottom is the poorest slum district
in king's landing
a maze-like warring of narrow streets
and dark alleys filled with tanneries
and ale houses
it's featured many times in game of
thrones including when arya stark takes
refuge there
after fleeing the red keep characters
from flea bottom include sir davos
sievert
gendry and carl tanner a brother of the
night's watch
the famous hedge knight sir duncan the
toll is also from flea bottom
the third and final new game of thrones
prequel is called the nine voyages
nine voyages refers to the great voyages
at sea made by corliss valerian known as
the sea snake
aboard the sea snake ship by the age of
7 and 30
corliss was hailed as the greatest
seafarer the seven kingdoms had ever
known
corliss was said to be as brilliant as
he was restless
and as adventurous as he was ambitious
cordless valerian known as the sea snake
was a fable the lord of the times master
of driftmark
and head of house valerian he was a
husband of princess rhaenys targaryen
during the dance of the dragons he
became handed to queen rhaenyra
targaryen
lord valerian journeyed to places
including panthos dragonstone and around
the bottom of estrus
as well as to lease tyroshanmir he
reached the fabled lands of etai and
ling
whose wealth doubled that of house
valerian and him and the ice wolf headed
north searching for passage around the
top of westeros
only to find frozen seats and icebergs
as big as mountains
the show chronicles scoreless valerian's
adventures
interestingly lord corliss will also
play a big role in house of the dragon
and this prequel will only get more
interest by fans when house of the
dragon airs
and everyone falls in love with the sea
snake character
in conclusion hb is working on many game
of thrones prequel shows
and besides house of the dragons none of
these will air before
2023 at our list but this is all good
news and don't worry about the release
dates of these prequels
as confirmed by hbo's president house of
the dragon wheeler in 2022 which is just
in one year
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia r martin's book
fire and blood vol 1
and on martin's yet unfinished farian
blood volume 2 book
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons the targaryen
civil war
which divided the entire kingdom and
launched a huge war that was fought from
129 ac to 131 hc
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first round
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight
divided the kingdoms in two targaryens
fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead house of the dragon is coming
with many targaryens and their dragons
as well as with other legendary
characters such as sea snake
craig stark and his winter wolves red
kraken and many more
thank you so much for watching and
please let me know which prequel you're
looking forward the most